bonjour Elena Elena Volochine votre
magazine hebdomadaire vu de Russie qui
analyse donc la propagande de Vladimir
Poutine sur fond de guerre en Ukraine et
cette semaine vous allez nous parler des
discours en Russie autour de ce que le
régime russe qualifie d'espion et de
traîtres à la patrie et oui bonsoir
Stéphanie donc des discours qui ne
datent ni de la guerre en Ukraine ni
même de la dernière décennie au pouvoir
de Vladimir Poutine mais qui en ce
moment prennent de l'ampleur vous savez
que cette semaine l'opposant est
journaliste russe Vladimir Karam Rosa a
été condamné à 25 ans de colonie
pénitentiaire parce qu'il aurait
notamment dénoncé les bombardements
russes contre les villes
ukrainiennes devant une chambre des
représentants celle de l'Arizona aux
États-Unis alors comme dans toutes les
affaires de trahison d'État le contenu
du dossier est tenu secret mes écoutés
comment la télévision russe a traité
cette condamnation
à 25 ans de colonies pénitentaires à
régime sévère pour trahison d'État fake
news sur l'armée russe et direction
d'une organisation indésirable
sans surprise les ambassadeurs des pays
les plus chers à l'agent de l'étranger
Vladimir karamuza sont aujourd'hui venus
ici au tribunal ceux de la
Grande-Bretagne du Canada et bien sûr
des États-Unis celui qui était leur
porte-voix pendant très longtemps selon
les enquêteurs ça donnait à la nuisance
et travailler ouvertement contre notre
pays
Vladimir carnosa est donc accusé par la
propagande russe d'être un traître à sa
patrie et un espion la propagande qui
accompagne ces simulacres de procès
elforge cette image de l'ennemi elle est
toujours aussi extrêmement confuse
écoutée par exemple de quoi se reporter
à envoyer devant le tribunal de la
chaîne NTV et bien il accuse l'opposant
bien entendu les accusations de trahison
d'État contre Vladimir karamuzza ne
viennent pas de nulle part l'opposant
était connu pour son amitié avec le
défunt sénateur américain John McCain de
plus qu'un amourza était un lobbyiste
des plus durs en faveur des sanctions
anti russes
américains ou encore appelé au sanctions
contre la Russie fait de vous un espion
et un traître à la patrie dans la Russie
de Vladimir Poutine oui encore une fois
ces discours ne sont pas nouveaux vous
avez entendu dans le premier extrait une
note de complotisme autour de la
présence des ambassadeurs étrangers et
notamment de l'ambassadeur américain et
aussi britannique et canadien à ce
procès à cette audience ces pays qui
représentent l'axe du mal voulant
détruire la Russie selon Vladimir
Poutine et en 2012 déjà alors que de
gigantesque manifestation avait lieu à
Moscou et dans d'autres villes russes
contre le retour au pouvoir de Vladimir
Poutine après sa passation avec Dimitri
Medvedev dans des élections qui ont été
truquées la propagande a commencé à
tourner à plein régime pour prétendre
que l'opposition qui organisait ces
manifestations étaient financées par des
ambassades étrangères en premier lieu
bien sûr l'ambassade américaine
regardait cet extrait
alors ce film intitulé anatomie de la
protestation il est tout sauf anodin
cela a été l'un des premiers films de
calomnie à l'encontre des opposants il a
été diffusé en 2012 sur cette même
chaîne NTV que vous avez vu tout à
l'heure avec cet extrait du procès de
Vladimir karamuza et ce film en
plusieurs volets il n'avait qu'un but
démontré à coup d'image détournées de
commentaires tendancieux mais aussi
d'images du FSB les services secrets
russes transmises à la chaîne de
télévision transmettre que diffuser que
les opposants les traîtres la cinquième
colonne comme l'appelait déjà c'est
propagande et bien elle était soi-disant
financé par l'Occident et les États-Unis
après ces films des dizaines
d'activistes et d'opposants ont déjà été
arrêtés et condamnés à plusieurs années
de colonie pénitentiaire l'opposant
russe Boris nmps of lui que vous allez
voir sur ces images il a été assassiné
et puis et puis la Russie a adopter
cette fameuse loi sur les agents de
l'étranger des méthodes et une
propagande Elena qui rappelle celle des
années 30 du temps de l'Union soviétique
oui nous avons interrogé à ce sujet
l'historien russe Sergueï proud
proudowski il travaille avec l'ONG prix
Nobel de la Paix mémorial sur les
répressions soviétiques son propre
grand-père a été déclaré espion et
ennemi du peuple sous stalini la QG il a
purgé pardon 15 ans dans les camps du
Goulag Sergueï prud'howski était de
passage aujourd'hui à Paris même
aujourd'hui même pour une conférence
organisée par la FIDH en partenariat
avec mémorial sur la réécriture de
l'Histoire par la Russie qui aurait
selon mémorial mené à la guerre en
Ukraine écoutons-le au micro d'elody
Radenac
cette position des autorités est proche
de la position en Union soviétique au
milieu des années 30
lorsque les gens étaient déclarés
ennemis du peuple
aujourd'hui les ennemis du peuple ont
été remplacés par le terme agent de
l'étranger c'est la même chose question
étrangers ou traître à l'époque
soviétique cette propagande est destinée
à anéantir la société civile en Russie
une guerre de grande ampleur ces
discours de propagande prennent aussi de
l'ampleur oui parce que tout comme en
2012 c'est aussi un moment crucial pour
la survie du régime de Vladimir Poutine
elle a la propagande effectivement
redouble d'intensité pour appeler aussi
à punir les opposants tous azimuts
la théorie qui les a tenues pendant des
décennies selon laquelle il pouvait
vendre et trahir ce pays elle porte
aujourd'hui ses fruits
car amourza est le premier mais il ne
sera certainement pas le dernier si
cet homme il est présenté comme un
politologue sur les chaînes de
télévision russe oui largement diffusé
il s'appelle Armen Gasparian et son
livre intitulé vous allez le voir des
nazifications de l'Ukraine on le voit
paru dès 2017 avec ce livre il est l'un
des théoriciens de l'invasion de
l'Ukraine pour en faire pour faire de ce
pays la Russie il est notamment
poursuivi par le parquet ukrainien pour
incitation au génocide pour ses appels
répétés à la destruction de l'Ukraine et
à l'extermination du peuple ukrainien
mais il n'est pas le seul à appeler à
l'emprisonnement aujourd'hui des
opposants qu'il qualifie de traîtres
écoutaient cet autre extrait d'une
émission quotidienne que l'on connaît
bien ici maintenant celle de Vladimir
soloviop qui s'en prend cette fois à
Alexei benedicto Flex directeur de la
station de radio indépendante éco de
Moscou c'était cette semaine
qui pour une raison qui m'échappe n'est
toujours pas en prison qui a pris sous
son aile tous ses traîtres il leur
offrait une plateforme pour s'exprimer
en Russie et il est toujours en liberté
alors que c'est un traître fini
enfin ils emploient la charge de
trahison d'État merci
de trahison d'État envers les Russes
d'espionnage envers les étrangers comme
avec le journaliste américain Evan
garchkovich oui effectivement un
tribunal moscovite a donc aussi confirmé
cette semaine la détention un provisoire
de notre confrère Evan arrêté en Russie
la propagande russe tourne aussi là à
plein régime et elle n'attend même pas
le simulacre de procès pour déclarer
Kevan est un espion mais comme dans le
cas de Vladimir karamoza et bien les
diatribe des propagandistes trahissent
légèrement le fait que cette affaire est
elle aussi politique écoutée
après son arrestation dans l'ouvrage
l'espion américain est amené au tribunal
de l'effort ovo sur ces images on fait
entrer l'espion qui porte un blouson
couleur moutarde et un capuchon sur la
tête
quel journaliste fait-il s'il ne faisait
pas un travail de journaliste c'est un
espion
sur notre territoire nous gardons un
nombre fou de journalistes qui font
franchement de la diffamation contre
nous et rien d'autre pourquoi ne les
expulse-t-on pas
pourquoi est-ce qu'on patiente jusqu'à
en arriver aux charges d'espionnage
donc sur ce plateau ils disent d'abord
Kevan à gargeskovic est un espion et
ensuite que son seul crime c'est une
soi-disant diffamation contre la Russie
oui autrement dit il est juste coupable
de faire son travail de journaliste en
recherchant la vérité sur le rôle de la
Russie dans cette guerre en Ukraine et
pour cela contrairement à ce que prétend
la propagande russe qui inverse les
rôles et bien il est lui-même victime
d'une campagne de diffamation dans les
médias russes pas seulement lui mais
aussi son photographe Patrick Kwak avec
lequel il travaillait sur ce dernier
reportage qui lui a valu son arrestation
voici ce que m'a raconté un peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui Patrick écouter les articles
ont été publiés sur moi et Evan tout à
peu près sur le même chemin c'est-à-dire
qui reprennent des événements de notre
biographie
personnelle et professionnelle et ils
essaient de les faire coïncider pour que
ça semble très suspect donc Evan c'est
par exemple le fait que il était
en a fait de haut niveau le fait que
ils soient issus d'une
université aux États-Unis le fait que
ses parents soient issus de
l'immigration soviétique pour moi ils
ont surtout en fait repris le fait que
j'ai travaillé pendant 11 ans en Chine à
travailler en tant photographe
indépendant à l'étranger en Chine et en
Russie n'est pas une situation
professionnelle
normale et possible donc forcément j'ai
un gain de pain à côté qui doit être
celui de travailler comme agent secret
voilà et Patrick quoi qui a quitté la
Russie dans la foulée vanne kerskovich
lui risque aujourd'hui jusqu'à 20 ans de
prison quant aux charges de trahison
d'État au lendemain de la condamnation
de Vladimir karamoza ladouma le
Parlement russe a porté la peine
maximale à perpétuité
merci Elena Elena Volochine donc pour
vue de Russie on vous retrouve vendredi
prochain à la même heure 18h45